Sie sind krank
und wollen nichts als leben.
Sie warten auf ein Organ,
das ein Verstorbener spendet.
Ein Leben geht zu Ende,
eines wird verlängert.
Die Organtransplantation
ist ein Eingriff, der bewegt.
Es geht um Ethik, Glaube,
Gesetz und Moral.
Um grosses Glück ...
Ich freue mich wie verrückt
auf diesen nächsten Abschnitt
in meinem Leben
und bin sehr dankbar,
dass ich das alles erleben darf.
... und um Ängste.
Was bedeutet die Transplantation
für die Empfängerinnen und Empfänger?
Wie genau läuft sie ab?
Wir hatten den Schnitt
um ca. 8.20 Uhr.
Und die Leber ist sehr schön.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Es braucht wahnsinnig Geduld.
Wie ist die Lebensqualität
nach dem grossen Eingriff?
Es geht um Warten,
Hoffnung
und vielleicht ― Erlösung.
Schweizerisches Kinderleberzentrum
in Genf.
Zeigst du mir deine Augen?
Mireya?
Zeigst du Mami deine Augen?
Frag du sie.
- Mireya, machst du die Augen auf?
Zeigst du Papi deine Augen?
- Komm, zeig sie!
Nach der Lebertransplantation liegt
Mireya noch immer in der Narkose.
Vor fast 12 Std.
kam sie aus dem Operationssaal.
Hoi, Prinzessin.
Es ist alles gut, alles tipptopp.
Nur weiter so.
- Du machst das super.
Super machst du das.
Kurz vor der Transplantation.
Wie viel?
- 80, 85.
Mireya Rast
leidet an einem seltenen Gendefekt.
Zweimal schon versagte ihre Leber.
Sie überlebte, wie durch ein Wunder.
Zwar hat sie sich erholt,
ein einfacher Infekt aber
kann wieder lebensbedrohlich werden.
Die Ärzte sehen nur eine Lösung
für die Heilung:
eine Lebertransplantation.
Ich möchte meine neue Leber haben.
Nach kurzer Wartezeit
wird Mireya in Genf operiert.
(Ärztin) Wunderschön.
Eine wunderschöne Leber.
Wir haben richtig Freude.
Die Eltern bangen im Warteraum.
Es geht ihr supergut.
- Ja.- Okay.
Die Kinderchirurgin Barbara Wildhaber
kann sie etwas beruhigen.
(Mutter) Hallo, Mireya.
Rund 10 Std.
dauerte die Transplantation -
sie ist so weit gut verlaufen.
Da muss sie durch -
dann müssen wir es auch.
... drei, hopp!
Der nächste Morgen. Mireya ist
noch nicht ganz zu sich gekommen.
Ist es normal, dass sie wach ist
und nachher wieder schläft?
Ja. Sie hat noch viele Medikamente,
die sie nicht ganz eliminiert hat.
Das braucht noch etwas Zeit.
Es wird in den nächsten Stunden
immer besser.
Müssen wir nicht pressieren,
dass sie erwacht?
Nein, das Wichtigste ist,
dass wir sehen, dass sie wach wird.
Und das tut sie ja.
- Genau.
Das kommt schon,
sie braucht noch etwas Zeit.
Hoho!
- Bravo! Du hörst alles, gell?
Du brauchst nur Zeit, Maminko,
nur Zeit.
Die kleine Patientin wird sich rasch
erholen, in diesen ersten Tagen.
Nicola Heyser
verlässt das Inselspital in Bern.
Sie lebt seit neun Jahren
mit einem Spenderherz.
Regelmässig
geht sie zur Untersuchung.
Ich freue mich natürlich
an den Tagen, an denen ich weiss:
Ich bin hier nur zur Kontrolle
und es ist alles gut.
An den Tagen,
an denen es mir nicht so gut geht,
ist es nicht so angenehm,
herzukommen.
Dann kommt alles wieder hoch,
auch die negativen Erlebnisse.
Nach der Transplantation
traten Komplikationen auf,
u.a. ein Nierenversagen.
Der Weg war so holprig,
dass sie kurz zweifelte,
ob die Operation
der richtige Schritt war.
Aber nur eine Transplantation
konnte ihr Leben retten.
Vor dem Eingriff
war Nicola Heyser unendlich müde.
Herzinsuffizienz, so die Diagnose.
Den 40. Geburtstag
verbringt sie mit ihrer Familie,
die aus Deutschland angereist ist.
Sie wartet auf die Transplantation.
(Alle im Chor)
# Happy birthday to you.
Ich habe schon bisschen Angst davor.
Wer weiss, wann man wieder
so fröhlich zusammen ist?
Das weiss man ja wirklich nicht.
Tochter Anna-Paula
übergibt ihr Geschenk.
Den Kristall finde ich schöner
und der bringt Glück.
Heute leben die beiden
in Niederwangen bei Bern.
Wie alle transplantierten Menschen
muss Nicola Heyser
Immunsuppressiva zu sich nehmen,
die verhindern, dass der Körper
das fremde Organ abstösst.
Diese Medikamente
haben Nebenwirkungen.
Ich muss das wegnehmen,
das entzündet sich.
Ich habe das Antibiotikum
gerade abgesetzt.
Jetzt bin ich erschrocken.
Ich dachte: Warum ist das so dunkel?
Das kann ja nicht sein.
Alles gut.
Wenn man nicht so Übung
mit dem Lockenstab hat ...
Ich habe mich
für die Konfirmation fertiggemacht,
bin abgerutscht, nur kurz dagegen.
Dann habe ich nicht gleich gekühlt,
weil wir keine Zeit hatten,
dann war es gleich entzündet.
Und dann tat es immer mehr weh.
Am Abend musste ich
in den Notfall gehen.
Das war bis hier unten
schon alles rot, runtergelaufen.
Wenn man immunsupprimiert ist,
passiert das schneller.
Das Immunsystem ist runtergesetzt
und der Körper hilft sich nicht.
Sonst würde er z.B.
das Herz wieder abstossen.
Diese Medikamente
erhöhen auch das Krebsrisiko.
Bei Nicola Heyser musste dreimal
weisser Hautkrebs entfernt werden,
dazu kam eine Unterleibsoperation
wegen auffälliger Veränderungen.
Aber:
Ohne die Medikamente geht es nicht.
Heute Abend noch der kleine
von beiden Immunsuppressionen
und etwas für die Gefässe,
das ist prophylaktisch,
damit es keine Ablagerungen gibt,
glaube ich.
Und jetzt habe ich gerade
Fieberbläschen.
Da muss ich extra
etwas Virushemmendes nehmen.
Sonst entzündet sich das alles
und ich kriege so dicke Lymphknoten.
Man sieht die ja kaum. Ich habe sie
gleich am Anfang genommen.
Aber wenn ich da nicht
rechtzeitig etwas nehme
oder ein bis zwei Tage warte,
dann ist alles geschwollen
und tut wahnsinnig weh.
Und dann noch Magnesium
und Kalium und Kalzium.
Das ist die Abenddosis.
Gleich nach der Transplantation
musste Nicola Heyser
über 30 Medikamente nehmen.
Dabei hatte sie schon
vor dem grossen Eingriff genug davon.
Manchmal denke ich, ich packe alles
in den Müllsack und raus damit.
Aber das ist
immer nur ein kurzer Moment.
Wegen der Transplantation
hat Nicola Heyser Momente
wie die Einschulung der Tochter
verpasst.
Da ist alles drin, also Turnsack ...
- Soll ich es zeigen?
Kannst du, ja.
Anna-Paula musste lernen, mit der
Krankheit der Mutter zu leben.
Ich hatte in letzter Zeit
schon manchmal Probleme damit.
Ich weiss auch nicht warum.
Es hat mich eingeholt
und ich habe gedacht:
Das war schon echt viel Glück,
dass sie noch bei mir sein kann.
Und das beschäftigt mich auch oft.
Ja. Aber ich geniesse
jeden Moment mit ihr.
Dass sie noch da ist,
macht mich sehr glücklich.
Mach Platz!
Brav.
Mach Platz, Isha!
Du musst sowieso an die Leine. Wenn
du eine Katze siehst, bist du weg.
* Sanft gezupfte Saitenmusik *
Inselspital Bern.
Auf der Intensivstation
liegt eine Patientin,
die nach einer Hirnblutung
verstorben ist.
Der Hirntod
wurde offiziell festgestellt.
Weil die Frau Organspenderin ist,
wird sie beatmet und gewärmt,
um die Organe zu erhalten.
Lucie Christen ist Organspende-
Koordinatorin am Inselspital.
Sie steht in ständigem Kontakt
mit den Angehörigen.
Die Familie sagte,
sie hätten gestern beim Frühstück
darüber gesprochen, dass sie eine
Patientenverfügung machen sollten.
Es war wie so oft im Leben
nie der richtige Zeitpunkt.
Offenbar hat sie sich
positiv zur Organspende geäussert.
Die Angehörigen gehen davon aus,
dass das in ihrem Sinn ist,
und haben so entschieden.
Der Zustand der Organe
ist medizinisch überprüft worden.
Die Empfänger sind bestimmt.
Jetzt geht es in den Operationssaal,
zur Organentnahme.
* Regelmässiges Piepen *
Die Angehörigen
haben den Dreharbeiten zugestimmt.
Aus Rücksicht auf sie
wurden für diesen Film
mehrere Organentnahmen gedreht
und die Bilder zusammengefügt.
Das dient der Anonymisierung.
Die meisten Organspenderinnen
und -spender haben einen Hirnschlag
oder eine Hirnblutung erlitten.
Die Organspende nach einem Hirntod
als primäre Todesursache ist häufiger
als die Organspende nach dem Herztod.
* Einzelne tragende Klavierakkorde *
Die Transplantationschirurgin
Vanessa Banz
wird die Organentnahme übernehmen,
nach einem vollen Arbeitstag.
* Regelmässiger Piepton *
Hier ist die Blutgruppenkarte 0070,
B positiv.
Mit Koordinatorin Lucie Christen
prüft sie die Unterlagen.
... unterschrieben und die
Freigabe bekommen zur Organentnahme.
0070.
Ja. Gut. Ja, danke.
- Okay.
* Regelmässiger Piepton *
Vanessa Banz kennt beide Seiten ―
implantieren und explantieren.
Jemand ist gestorben.
Das belastet viel mehr
als wenn man weiss,
da ist jemand, der lebt,
und man darf eine Operation machen.
Man muss extrem vorsichtig arbeiten,
damit man an einem Organ,
das sehr rar ist,
keine Verletzung macht,
die dazu führt, dass das Organ
nicht transplantabel wäre.
Eigentlich ist es eine Operation
wie andere auch.
Aber für einmal nicht
zugunsten des Operierten,
sondern der Organempfänger.
Zwei Leben berühren sich.
Die Kosten der Entnahme trägt
die Krankenkasse des Organempfängers.
Insgesamt kommt eine Transplantation
auf 100'000-250'000 Fr. zu stehen.
Ist gut, können wir anfangen?
Schnitt.
Ciao, Markus.
Hier ist Lucie aus Bern.
Ich wollte dir sagen:
Wir haben halbpünktlich gestartet.
Wir hatten um 20.18 Uhr
den Schnitt für die MOE.
Ich melde mich wieder,
wenn wir wissen,
wie die Leber aussieht für Genf.
Mhm, tipptopp.
Vielen Dank.
Lucie Christen überwacht
und protokolliert.
Ich bin
die Verbindungsperson gegen aussen
mit Meldung an Swisstransplant,
dass die Operation angefangen hat.
Später ein Anruf ans Zentrum,
das die Leber bekommt,
wie sie aussieht.
Und alle Zeiten werden dokumentiert:
Wann war die Spülung?
Wann kam das Organ raus?
Nachher die Mithilfe
beim Verpacken und Verschicken.
Kann der Tisch etwas runter?
Sorry.
(Frau) Der Tisch geht runter.
- Ja.
Das ist gut.
Den Strom
bitte noch mal hochstellen, auf 100.
Ich weiss,
es ist schwierig zu verstehen,
aber aus chirurgischer Sicht
ist es eine wunderschöne Operation.
Man sieht den ganzen Aufbau,
wie der Mensch gemacht ist.
Ich finde es per se
wahnsinnig faszinierend,
wie das alles funktioniert,
wie fein das abgestimmt ist,
wie sinnvoll alles ist.
Alles hat einen Zweck
und ist genau dort, wo es sein muss.
Das hilft schon,
um etwas abzulenken.
Das ist vielleicht das falsche Wort.
Als Chirurg muss man sagen:
Es ist eine wunderschöne Operation,
bei der man den jungen Leuten
viel beibringen und zeigen kann,
weil man alles sieht.
* Einzelne
melancholische Klaviertöne *
Universitätsspital Genf.
Eine Woche ist seit
Mireyas Transplantation vergangen.
Seit der letzten Nacht
ist sie auf der Intensivstation.
Es sind Komplikationen aufgetreten.
Warten sind wir ja gewohnt.
Was denkst du,
wie es für Mireya ist?
Die Eltern sind am Ende.
Die ständige Angst
zerrt an den Nerven.
Ich gehe mal schauen.
Jetzt müssen wir warten,
was rauskommt.
Es ist einfach komisch.
Denn in den letzten Tagen
hat sie Fortschritte gemacht.
Jetzt macht sie eigentlich
einen Rückschritt.
Das ist erstens
nicht gut für Mireya.
Und für uns auch nicht.
Es ging immer weiter nach oben.
Und irgendwann ...
Jetzt geht es schlecht.
Dann fällt man selbst
auch in ein Loch.
Ja.
Die neu transplantierte Leber -
es handelt sich um den Teil
einer Erwachsenenleber - blutet.
Die Chirurgin Barbara Wildhaber
versucht jetzt,
die Flüssigkeit
in einem Schlauch abzuleiten.
Mireyas Bauch ist stark gebläht,
sie möchte sofort operiert werden.
Ach, Maus!
Gell Mireya, du möchtest in den Ops,
weil du dich so unwohl fühlst?
Ja!
- Ich verstehe das.
Wenn ich den Entscheid treffe,
dass wir in den Ops gehe, ist es,
weil ich möchte, dass es ihr in ein
paar Tagen wieder geht wie gestern.
Damit wir schnell
vorwärtsmachen können.
Obwohl es nochmal ein Abtauchen ist,
können wir schneller vorwärtsmachen.
Sie ist so vernünftig, unglaublich.
- Mireya, das machst du super, echt.
Sie will in den Operationssaal.
Frau Doktor will nicht operieren,
wenn es nicht sein muss.
Aber wenn es nicht geht,
operiert sie, ja?
Wir müssen effektiv
noch einmal operieren.
Sie hat in der Nacht geblutet,
brauchte Bluttransfusionen.
Es ist noch nicht ganz still.
In diesen Situationen
muss man manchmal das Blut ausräumen
und nochmals eine Operation machen.
Es ist nicht ganz einfach
für die Familie.
Auch für uns nicht,
für Mireya als allerletztes.
Es ist ernst,
aber wir wissen, was zu tun ist.
* Dumpfe Gitarrenklänge *
Sie bereiten alles für dich vor
oder ich vergesse es.- Stress.
Was?
- Stress.
Sie kommt gleich.
Langsam atmen, langsam.
(Flüsternd) Nicht vergessen, Mireya:
Ich habe dich sehr lieb.
Hast du gehört?
- Mhm.
Gell? Ich habe dich sehr lieb.
Hm? Ist gut?
* Sanfte, tiefe Klaviermusik *
* Lautes Ein- und Ausatmen *
Nach 2,5 Std.
ist es überstanden.
Mireya!
- Hallo, Maminko.
Hallo, Schätzelinko.
Der Eingriff ist gut verlaufen.
Voilà.
Stress sie nicht.
- Sie stressen sie nicht.
Sie schläft einfach noch,
weil sie noch Medikamente hat.
Sie sehen, sie atmet ruhig,
alles bestens.
Das ist die Hauptsache.
Ist der Bauch
nicht mehr geschwollen?
* Piepen *
Ah, super.
- Butterweich.
Wie früher, wie gestern.
- Ich traue mich nicht, zu schauen.
Es sieht aus wie vorher.
- Aha, okay.
Einfach, dass der Bauch
nicht mehr schwanger ist.
Das Baby ist draussen.
- Okay, danke.
* Unverständliche Gesprächsfetzen *
Es war, wie wir gesagt haben:
Es hatte viel Flüssigkeit und ich
habe keine Blutungsquelle gefunden.
Wahrscheinlich,
wenn man die Leberschnittfläche hat,
hat es oben am meisten geklebt,
dort hat sie wohl etwas geblutet.
Und wenn die Koagel,
die sich bilden ...
Wie sagt man das auf deutsch?
Koagel? Blutgerinnsel. Voilà.
Das hätte ich nicht gewusst.
- Blutgerinnsel.
Ist ein Blutgerinnsel vor einer Blu-
tung, hört es nicht auf zu bluten.
Dann nimmt man die Blutgerinnsel
raus, dann ist fertig.
Aber die Leber ist wunderschön.
- Arbeitet sie gut?
So, wie es aussieht, sowieso.
Das sehen wir in den Untersuchungen.
Aber die Leber selber
ist wirklich ganz schön.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Katja Rast
weicht auch auf der Intensivstation
nicht von Mireyas Seite.
Ah, schau jetzt!
Hilfst du mir schon?
Rivaldo!
Die ehemalige Spitzensportlerin
Nicola Heyser kommt zur Arbeit.
Sie trainiert Rivaldo,
das Turnierpferd eines Kunden ...
Komm, Rivaldo!
... und gibt einigen Kunden
Reitunterricht.
Hey! Na, mein Freund?
Wir müssen noch
ein bisschen was machen, nicht?
Tochter Anna-Paula reitet erfolgreich
bei Nachwuchsturnieren mit.
* Friedliche Gitarrenmusik *
Vor der Herztransplantation
war Nicola Heyser so geschwächt,
dass sie nicht mehr reiten konnte.
Der Sport war immer mein Leben.
Das ist schon
ein sehr grosser Frust für mich.
Es ist nicht die Priorität,
dass ich wieder aufs Pferd komme.
Aber wenn es im glücklichsten Fall
wieder möglich ist,
dass ich ein Pferd reiten kann,
dann wäre ich überglücklich.
Das wäre Ostern und Weihnachten
zusammen, das wäre wirklich schön.
Aber das ist
sicher nicht das Wichtigste.
Das Wichtigste ist, dass ich wieder
ein normales Leben führen kann.
Nicola Heyser feierte
als Dressurreiterin grosse Erfolge.
Sie stammt aus einer Dynastie
von Reitern und Pferdezüchtern.
Es macht mich schon traurig.
Denn man hat eine Beziehung
und es ist irgendwie so ...
Ja.
Es ist schon hart.
Es dauerte lange, bis Nicola Heyser
wieder zu Kräften kam.
Dann aber wollte sie
trotz des gedrosselten Immunsystems
zurück zu den Pferden,
gegen den Rat der Ärzte.
Die haben mir eigentlich
damals gesagt,
dass ich sicher nicht mehr
in den Stall darf.
Ich habe für mich immer gesagt:
Ich bin mit dem Dreck
gross geworden.
Seit ich ein kleines Kind war,
war ich jeden Tag im Stall.
Ich würde es gerne probieren.
Sie haben gesagt, die Gefahr,
dass die Pilze und Sporen,
die hier herumfliegen,
auf die Lunge gehen, ist sehr gross.
Nachher macht die Lunge ein Problem.
Nachher haben sie gesagt, ich soll
es probieren, aber vorsichtig.
Und ich habe nie Probleme gehabt.
Es ist mir oft bewusst,
dass es ein Geschenk ist, jeden Tag,
dass ich hingehen kann.
Bist du schon fertig?
- Ja.
Die Pferde verlangen ihr alles ab.
Ich merke das am Abend schon, ich
bin dann schon ziemlich erledigt.
Und ich glaube,
ich könnte meinen Tag
nicht mehr zu 100 %
mit dem Beruf Reiten ausfüllen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
* Rhythmisches Zungenschnalzen *
Anna-Paula?
- Hm?
Bist du fertig?
- Ja.
Oh! Malinka ist zickig.
* Nicola Heyser lacht. *
Schere, bitte.
Nein, ist gut. Strom.
Im Inselspital hat Vanessa Banz
inzwischen
die Organentnahme vorbereitet.
* Leises, unverständliches Gespräch *
Salut, Marie-Claude,
c'est Lucie de Berne.
Die Leber ist sehr schön.
Wir würden sie ...
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Sie hat ganz scharfe Kanten,
eine ganz glatte Oberfläche.
Wir würden sie gerne
selber behalten.
Okay?
Wann möchtest du noch ein Telefon?
Ja, das kommt hin, denke ich.
Der Patient wird noch immer beatmet,
der Kreislauf gestützt.
Er ist narkotisiert - trotz Hirntod.
Es braucht eine Narkose,
auch weil gewisse Reflexe
noch vorhanden sind.
Der Patient muss voll relaxiert
sein, damit wir operieren können.
Weil der Patient hirntot ist,
müssen wir den Kreislauf
nach wie vor voll unterstützen.
Deshalb braucht es eine Narkose,
die uns hilft.
Es sind Reflexe des Rückenmarks,
die unterdrückt werden müssen.
Für die Entnahme der Lunge ist -
mitten in der Nacht -
Sven Hillinger angereist,
leitender Arzt am Zürcher Unispital.
Die Spezialisten der Empfängerzentren
explantieren die Organe
für ihre Patienten meistens selber.
Vanessa Banz nutzt die Gelegenheit
für eine kurze Pause.
Ein Kaffee gegen die Müdigkeit.
Die Organentnahme
und -transplantation
ist bis auf die Lebendspender-
transplantationen nicht planbar.
Wenn man Dienst hat, kann man sich
nicht die ganze Woche freihalten,
falls etwas kommt.
Unter Umständen kommt viel
oder gar nicht.
Wir schauen im Team schon,
dass man sich gegenseitig aushilft.
Aber manchmal
kann man nicht vermeiden,
dass du in der Nacht arbeitest
und am nächsten Tag weitermachst.
In dieser Phase assistiert
Vanessa Banz ihrem Kollegen.
Es steht
der entscheidende Moment bevor:
Der Blutkreislauf wird unterbrochen,
die Hauptschlagader abgeklemmt.
Könnt ihr laut sagen, wenn ihr
clampt? Hier ist noch nichts.
* Räuspern *
Clamp heisst das in der Fachsprache.
Nur kurz: Schneidest du oben rein?
Eis haben wir parat?- Ja.
Der Körper wird mit Eis gefüllt.
Die Maschinen werden abgestellt,
nur die Lunge wird noch kurz
mit Sauerstoff versorgt.
Eine Spülflüssigkeit
ersetzt das Blut.
Die Narkose erübrigt sich jetzt.
In seltenen Fällen
wird das auch den Profis zu viel.
Wenn jemand sehr Mühe hat,
wenn er aus persönlichen Gründen
oder aus Glaubensgründen findet,
er könne unmöglich hier drin sein,
finden sie immer
eine Lösung im Team.
Sven Hillinger begutachtet die Lunge.
Er ist zufrieden.
* Piepen, einzelne Saitentöne *
Die Lunge kann 6 bis max. 8 Std.
ausserhalb des Körpers bleiben.
Rasch machen sich die Ärzte
des Universitätsspitals Zürich
auf den Rückweg.
Vielen Dank.
Viel Glück, vielen Dank.
- Tschüss!
Auf Wiedersehen.
- Vielen Dank.
Du hast dir alles,
du hast den ganzen ...
Für die Entnahme
der verbleibenden Organe
übernimmt wieder Vanessa Banz
den Lead.
Das Kinderspital in Genf.
Eine Woche ist vergangen
seit Mireyas neuerlicher Operation.
Sie ist hungrig,
obwohl die Nacht unruhig verlief.
Mireya hatte Angst vor
den Medikamenten des nächsten Tages.
Sie hat in der Nacht 100-mal
die Schwester gerufen in Nacht.
Joghurt, Eis, den warmen ...
- ... Wärmebeutel.
Ja.
Essen?
- Schon wieder Essen?
Immer noch dasselbe.
- Willst du das Gipfeli oder ...
Schoggigipfel, Berliner,
Äpfel, Bananen, Joghurt ...
Joghurt besser nicht.
- Apfel.
Salzstangen?
- Wieder einen Apfel?- Nein.
Ja, Banane.
- Was jetzt?
Banane.
Aber Salzstangen sind gut, Mireya.
- Banane!
Lass sie doch. Banane stopft auch
und hat noch Vitamine drin.
Wie viel? So, bis hier?
- Mhm.
* Klopfen *
Jetzt geht's los.- Ja.
Guten Morgen oder guten Mittag.
- Morgen.
Hoi, du.
- Hoi.- Hoi!
Bist du immer noch eingepackt
in all die Sachen?
Wolltest du kein T-Shirt anziehen?
Wo ist mein Schoggi-Drink?
- Oh! Du bist fertig.
Du hast ihn schon getrunken.
Ihr habt versprochen,
noch einen zu kaufen.
Ja, ist gut.
- Hallo! Eines nach dem andern.
Gell?
- Und meine Glace?
Die hast du gegessen.
- Du bist schon die Prinzessin.
Aber eines nach dem andern, gell?
Sie pressiert immer so.
- War das früher schon so?
Also ist es wieder die alte Mireya
Sehr gut.
Und Sie haben noch Fragen,
Frau Rast?
Im Moment nicht.
- Okay.
Das ist so wenig.
- Wir holen noch etwas anderes.
(Ärztin) Weisst du was?
Iss mal das, dann schauen wir.
(Mutter) Ich bin froh,
wenn du das alles isst.
Sie ist am Nörgeln,
aber das ist ja auch normal.
Es ist eine Woche her,
dass man wieder auftun musste,
weil sie geblutet hat.
Sie hat sich extrem schnell erholt.
Innerhalb von zwei Tagen war sie
wie vorher, zurück auf der Autobahn,
wie ich es nannte.
Sie macht es gut.
Wunderbar.
Nur langsam, gell, langsam.
Auf dem Programm
steht Physiotherapie.
Geht es nicht mehr?
- Hm, hm.
Müde?
* Leise, unverständliche Gespräche *
Go!
* Virtuose Gitarrenmusik,
Jauchzer *
* Lachen *
* Unverständliche Laute *
Sch!
* Lachen *
* Poltern *
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Mami hält dich.
Steh hinter sie, sie schwankt.
- Ja, mache ich.
Nicola Heyser und Anna-Paula
werden bald Abschied nehmen.
Sie verlassen die Schweiz
und ziehen um,
in die Nähe von Hamburg,
Nicolas Heimat.
Also.
Kannst du einmal
Geschirr reinschreiben?
Diverses oder Teller.
- Einmal Besteck und Geschirr.
Ein grosser Schritt,
nach 22 Jahren in der Schweiz.
Das hat sich so ergeben,
auch durch den Tod meines Vater.
Meine Schwester
macht jetzt den Hof alleine
und der ist recht gross.
Und dann ist mir auch
bewusst geworden,
dass ich doch Zeit
mit meiner Familie geniessen muss -
oder möchte, nicht muss -,
die mir auch sehr fehlt.
Ich habe immer viel Heimweh gehabt.
Als dann meine Schwester fragte,
ob ich nicht nach Hause kommen will,
dachte ich: ja.
Viel mehr Schweres
darf ich da nicht reintun.
Dann nehme ich den ...
Ein bisschen geht noch.
So, du kannst laufen.
Ja, lauf! Ja, ja, ja. Komm!
Bald sind es zehn Jahre, seit Nicola
Heyser mit dem Spenderherz lebt.
Komm, lauf!
Ich muss manchmal
schon recht beissen.
Es ist nicht so,
dass mir immer alles leichtfällt.
Ja.
Aber im Grossen und Ganzen
bin ich sehr zufrieden.
Ich habe gar nicht erwartet,
dass es jemals wieder so gut wird.
Aber das ist immer so: Wenn man
ein Zückerchen gekriegt hat,
hat man das Gefühl,
es könnte noch mehr gehen
und vielleicht noch ein
leckeres Schokoladen-Mousse kommen,
aber das kommt nicht mehr.
* Lachen *
Fein.
Grüessech!
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Ganz unbeschwert
ist der Alltag nicht.
Ja, es sind schon Ängste da,
ich kann es nicht anders sagen.
Man kann es
für Tage und Wochen wegstecken.
Und dann fragt man sich natürlich
auch: Wie lange geht es noch so?
Man spricht nicht so darüber.
Denn warum soll man Angst haben,
wenn es gut geht?
Aber ich weiss auch,
dass der Körper
unter den Medikamenten, die ich
täglich nehmen muss, recht leidet.
* Sanfte, sphärische Gitarrenmusik *
Statistisch betrachtet
leben nach zehn Jahren
noch mehr als 65 %
der Herztransplantierten.
Gemäss den Zahlen
des Unispitals Zürich
sind es nach 20 Jahren
noch rund 50 %.
Hast du mir bitte eine grobe Schere?
Am Operationstisch steht Vanessa Banz
kurz vor der Entnahme
von Leber und Nieren.
Darf ich bitte
eine Neuroschere haben?
Einfach eine, die schneidet.
Seid ihr bereit?
- Ja.
* Sauggeräusche *
Hältst du den Kübel, bitte?
Die Leber.
Gut, danke.
Tuch, bitte. Kann ich bitte
die feine Schere haben?
Sie wird sofort gespült, damit
verbleibendes Blut nicht gerinnt.
Ist Lucie da?
- Ja.
Hochhalten. Hat Genf etwas gesagt
wegen speziell langen Gefässen?
Überhaupt nicht, nein.
Sie haben keine Wünsche geäussert.
Die Organe
werden standardmässig verpackt.
Das ist wirklich eine schöne Leber.
- Mhm.
Die Leute fragen immer:
"Bis wann kann ich spenden?"
Es gibt Leute, die mit 50 eine Leber
haben, die nicht mehr optimal ist.
Dann gibt es Leute mit 86,
die eine wunderschöne Leber haben,
die gut dazu geschaut haben,
bei denen man sagen muss:
Die würde man sofort nehmen.
Mit beiden Händen.
- Gut, ich habe sie.
* Einzelne monotone Saitenklänge *
Das ist die rechte Niere.
- Danke schön. Niere rechts.
Niere rechts.
Der Versand der unbezahlbaren Fracht
liegt in der Verantwortung
von Koordinatorin Lucie Christen ...
Niere rechts.
- Okay, Niere rechts.
Droite, für Genf.
- Für Genf, ja.
... und des spezialisierten
Transportunternehmens AAA.
* Sanfte, tiefe Klavierakkorde *
Der Körper des Organspenders
ist wieder zugenäht worden.
Das ist mein Abschied:
an die Schulter fassen,
wenn alles vorbei ist.
Wenn ich
auf die Intensivstation komme,
trete ich auch so in Kontakt
mit den Menschen, die dort liegen.
Eine kurze Berührung und ich
merke mir das Gesicht des Menschen.
Im Aufbahrungsraum werden sich auch
die Angehörigen verabschieden können.
In Genf wartet Familie Rast
auf den Bescheid der Ärzte.
Ein Monat ist
seit der Transplantation vergangen.
Alle drei möchten nach Hause.
Es war heftig. Ich hätte nie
gedacht, dass es so heftig wird.
Was? Was?
Die Zeit, seit sie angerufen haben,
bis jetzt.
Plötzlich hat sie gesagt,
sie wolle Mami und Papi nicht mehr,
sie wolle allein sein.
Mhm.
- Das war die Horrorzeit.
Wenn du von deinem Kind
solche Worte hörst,
dass sie sterben will
und so Zeug ...
Für mich war das schlimmer
als die Operation.
Eines Tages
verweigerte Mireya die Medikamente.
Sie mussten ihr zweimal mit einer
Ernährungssonde verabreicht werden.
Auch heute gibt es einen Rückschlag.
Mireyas Bauch ist wieder geschwollen.
Hallo. Schlechte Nachricht?
- Ein bisschen.
Es wird nicht möglich,
heute nach Hause zu gehen.
Fast gedacht.
- Morgen?
Ich habe es auch gedacht.
- Das weiss ich nicht.
Es gibt ein bisschen Flüssigkeit
in der Lunge.
Oh. Das ist nicht gut.
- Ja.
Es gibt zu viel Flüssigkeit
und es geht in die Lunge.
Heute machen wir die Punktion
für die Flüssigkeit. - Nein!
Ich habe schon zu viel erlebt.
- Was hast du?
Wenn der Arzt das sagt,
was willst du machen?
Mireyka, du siehst selber,
dass dein Bauch gross ist.
Ja, ich will einfach mal heim.
Die Eltern wissen:
Die bevorstehende Entnahme der
Gewebeflüssigkeit ist entscheidend.
Bei schlechtem Bescheid,
wenn Fett in der Flüssigkeit ist,
arbeitet die Leber
noch nicht richtig.
Lachgas soll Mireya
durch den Eingriff helfen.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Es ist wichtig,
dass sie sich nicht bewegt.
Nicht bewegen. Voilà.
Ich halte deine Hände, Mireya,
das ist wichtig.
Das tut aber Millionen weh!
* Wimmern *
Aufhören!
Jetzt heisst es warten -
auf die Laborergebnisse.
Auch für die Ärzte.
Wir haben gute Nachrichten.
- Ah!
Hallo!
- Wir haben gute Nachrichten.
Also, raus damit!
Fast, fast. Wie geht's?
(Mireya) - Gut.
Und Mireya?
- Sind alle Ärzte da, die ...
Ja, keine Angst!
- Nicht schlecht.
Was ist die gute Nachricht?
Es hatte ja zuletzt
zu viel Fett in der Flüssigkeit.
Und das ist jetzt nicht mehr.
Das ist gut.
Also kein Fett drin?
- Mhm.
Uff!
Also wir haben gedacht,
dass ihr übers Wochenende
in den Urlaub könntet
und dass wir uns am Montag
wiedersehen für eine Kontrolle.
Aber Papi, das ist
eine ganz gute Nachricht.- Ja.
Hast du gehört?
Dann haben die Pfleger Ruhe von dir.
- Mami, Mami!
Wir könnten selber Essen machen.
Aber darauf achten: ohne Fett.
* Lachen, hüpfende Klavierklänge *
Frische Luft, Mireya.
Mireya darf das Wochenende
in der Wohnung verbringen,
die das Spital
den Eltern zur Verfügung stellt.
Eine Erlösung.
- Mireytscha, Mireytscha.
Eins, zwei.
Hältst du sie?
- Ich mache es.
* Fernsehgeräusche im Hintergrund *
Bist du entspannt?
- Mhm, sehr.
Sehr? Gut.
Musst du den einen Sirup nicht
in den Kühlschrank tun?- Nein.
Sie hat nicht mehr den,
der in den Kühlschrank muss.
Okay.
- Der muss nicht.
Jetzt ist Katja in der Verantwortung,
die Medikamente zu richten.
Aufpassen wegen dem Glas dort.
- Ah, das ist die.
Warte.
- Das ist die, ähm ...
Riecht irgendwie wie Jägermeister.
Ist gut?
Gib her, ich trinke das schon mal.
- Ja, ist gut. Hier.
Eins, zwei.
Mami!
Brav, brav.
So.
- Ist gut?
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
* Lachen *
Irgendwie komisch ohne Schläuche.
Kannst du nachher
diese Lampe ausmachen?
Ja, ja, geht schon.
Und so geht es weiter:
Eliane Gutzwiller
ist lungentransplantiert
und leidet unter einer
chronischen Abstossung des Organs.
Auf Social Media
berichtet sie offen über ihr Leben.
Für mich ist das
eine Art der Bewältigung.
Christian Reutemann
wartet auf eine Spenderlunge.
Ein paar Minuten auf dem Fitnessvelo,
mehr geht nicht mehr. Und ...
Mireya Rast und ihre Familie
sind endlich wieder zu Hause.